for today i'm really delighted
um to introduce our third guest speaker
who's marcorellio ranzato um so he's
originally from italy
and then worked at nyu with young mccoon
and then has a postdoc with jeffrey
hinton so he's a very
diet on the wall deep learning
researcher a lot of his
original work was in areas like feature
learning
and vision but over the last few years
he's really
turned his interest to natural language
processing
and in particular in the last few years
he's worked a huge amount
in looking at machine translation in
general and particular machine
translation
for languages for which less resources
are
available so i saw a talk of his about
six months ago on this topic
and through him and his team at facebook
they've really got a lot of exciting new
work
in ways to bring neural machine
translation
up to the next level and so i hope that
this would be a really
great opportunity for everyone to see
some of the latest and most exciting
techniques in your
machine translation that's sort of the
next level beyond what
we talked about and you guys all did in
assignments four and five for the class
um so take it away with marco elliot
okay thank you so much chris for
inviting me
um let me just put my face i'm here
hi everybody i'm gonna disable it now so
you can focus on the presentation
um so share
i hope you should be able to see my
presentation now
okay so i'm very excited to uh tell you
a little bit about
low resource machine translation and
let's start by
revisiting the machine translation
problem so
let's say that we want to translate
between english and french
and we start with a big
training set where we have a collection
of sentences
uh in english with their corresponding
translation in french
and this is what we call a parallel data
set
and in particular the sentences in
english we call them
source sentences right and the
corresponding sentences in french are
what we call the target sentences
and now uh the learning problem
is about uh for a given uh
sentence in english you want to predict
the corresponding
sentence in french and the way that we
do that
is by minimizing the cross entropy loss
which maximizes the law probability of
the
reference human translation given the
input source sentence
and we do this by stochastic grainy
descent
using uh as architecture a sequence to
sequence with attention that
uh as far as i know you studied and
and you had the homework on a few weeks
ago
and then after you train this at this
time
you are given a novel english sentence
and you want to produce
the corresponding translation in order
to do that
we usually employ a heuristic
search method like beam that tries to
find
approximately the target sentence that
maximizes the law probability given
the the given uh source sentence
so this is uh at the high level how
machine translation works and
let's think about the assumptions that
we have been making
uh through this discussion so the first
assumption is that we are working with
two uh fairly related languages like
english and french and the second
uh assumptions that we have at our
disposal a large data set of parallel
sentences because here we are
essentially doing
uh supervised learning right and it is a
beautiful example of end-to-end
supervised learning but
that relies on the availability of a
large
parallel data set and so
in the world there are more than 6 000
languages
and needless to say
most of these languages don't belong to
the european family
for which much of the recent research on
machine translation has been focusing on
and even if you look at english english
is spoken by
less than five percent of uh as native
languages
is spoken by less than five percent of
the world population
and so uh if you
were to count how many people speak a
certain language and you look at that
histogram
it's a very heavy distribution so even
if you
take the top tens spoken languages
you find that this accounts for less
than 50 of the people in the world
and now if you look at the
very far right of the tail
uh those are languages for which there
are very few speakers and
essentially there is no digitized data
material for you to train anything so
for
for those i think it's almost hopeless i
would say
but in the middle of this tale we have
a lot of languages for which there is
some
digital data and for which we don't have
good ways to translate
nowadays if you think about major
providers like google
yandex baidu facebook and so forth they
provide
translation for the top 100 languages so
we are still
very much at the far right of this
long distribution and so uh if we
if we're able to uh um
improve machine translation in the
middle i think we could do
uh we it would be very impossible right
but so what happens as we walk down this
tail
so what happens is that the amount of
data
of parallel data decreases and
that correlates very much with the
quality of the
automatic machine translation systems
that we have in particular
as you can see here at some point there
is actually a drastic drop in
accuracy of your machine translation
system
so
[Music]
so perhaps the initial
picture that we had in mind is a little
different so now if we
take a fairly large source language like
nepali which is the language spoken in
nepal
a lovely country northeast of india
with more than 25 million people so it's
not as
a handful of people
first of all the amount of training data
is not as much as english french is
much much less than that and here
let's use a different visual
representation so let's use
fear rectangles with a color that
corresponds to the
language so the blue rectangle is
english data and the
red rectangle is nepali data
now in practice
the the parallel dataset is not
just such a monolithic thing because
some part
originates in english and some parts
originates in nepali and now let's
represent
uh the uh nepali translations
of english data with an empty
rectangle where the column corresponds
to the language and whether you feel it
or not
depends whether this is translation is
so whether this is a human translation
or whether it is
data originating in the language so in
this case we take
data that originates in english and we
translate into nepali and so this is the
empty red rectangle and the same for
when you go from nepali to english now
in general the data that originates in
english and the data that originates
nepali come from different may come from
different domains
so here on the y-axis you have the
domain and so
in this example that i totally made up
but it's pretty um
indicative of what happens in practice
you may have the
english sentences may come from let's
say bible
and so the nepali here are translations
from the bible
and the nepali sentences may
come from parliamentary data okay
so you may agree with me that
translating a novel sentence
from the bible is not a super
interesting task
because the pipeline is a pretty static
data set right
and so maybe we want to translate news
data
and but so
in practice we don't have any parallel
data
in the news domain perhaps what we have
so what we
really want to do at the end is
translate sentences from this
uh test site that is english news into
nepali
but all we have in the news domain is
at most monolingual data both in english
and nepali so these are
english sentences that are not aligned
at all with the nepali sentences over
here
there just happened to be just data that
you
got from new sources okay and so this is
a pretty complicated learning setting
because
you have a little bit of parallel
sentences
and uh that are in a different domain
from the test set
and all you have in the domain of
interest
is monolingual data and
in fact you may have also
some other parallel in another language
let's say hindi
that is in the same family as nepali
but maybe this is in a different domain
let's say books
and perhaps you have also monolingual
data in hindi that is also in the book
domain
so in fact
what you really in practice what you
find is that you may have
a lot of languages here from which you
could learn
and and a lot of domains
and all you want to do at the end is to
be able to translate
news data in english into nepali but you
don't have any
supervision for that you don't have any
label data and parallel data for that
what you have is a bunch of data in
different domains and
in different languages and so the
question is how can you leverage
all these data in order to perform your
original translation task
and so this is a mondrian-like learning
study
which is pretty tricky
and this is going to be the topic of
this lecture
and so um there is not
a very um clear definition of what lord
resource machine translation is but
loosely speaking a language bar can be
considered low resource
when the number of parallel sentences in
domain
is less than ten thousand okay
and as uh order of magnitude
and uh and this is very little
particularly if you think that modern
neural machine translation systems have
easily hundreds of millions of
parameters
and so there are several challenges
there are challenges that pertain the
data
and challenges that pertain to the model
design
so in terms of the data it is very hard
to
get data to train right it is very hard
to figure out
where to get the data to train data that
is in
in a domain similar to the domain that
you are interested in eventually
translating
uh if that doesn't exist how to get data
in
similar languages on other domains
and even how to get data to evaluate
your system on
and on the modeling side uh there is the
question of of course how to
learn with solitude supervision so
little direct supervision at the very
least
and how to operate in this
framework for which we have so many
languages and so many domains
so uh
so as uh chris mentioned the very
beginning
my background is not really nlp my um
i've always been interested in learning
with supervision
and i think working in lords machine
translation is
at least personally a very unique
opportunity
it's a very rare case in which my
research agenda is aligned with an
application
because um in
resource machine translation you don't
have much level data and you need to
make
the best use of auxiliary tasks and
auxiliary data
in order to perform well and this is a
general problem
and at the same time machine translation
is
a real application is something that if
we improve we can
really uh have a chance to improve
uh a lot of applications and and
the life of a lot of people
so uh this concludes my introduction
about
lord resource machine translation and um
the issues that we face when working on
these languages
before and let me
just pause for a second saying that the
outline of the stock was
around three pillars that in a way
define
the cycle of research so the first
pillar is data
so i'm going to review
how we can get data in particular for
evaluation
so data is the prerequisite to do
anything
in our life as a machine learner
practitioners right
and then afterwards i'm going to move to
the modeling so
describing some algorithms to
learn on low resource languages
and finally i will conclude with some
work on analyzing
uh what the model does when we train on
low resource languages
and in practice like throughout my
work here i keep going around the circle
because
as i figured out uh the issues that we
have with the data with the model then
i make a map with a data set that better
fits the kind of problems that i'm
interested in
and then i may go back to the modeling
side to improve the models and and so
and so forth
okay and here i'm giving some references
of the works that i'm presenting
not all of them and just so
uh and just to be clear these are this
is not meant to be a chronological
survey so these are not necessarily
the works that introduced a certain a
certain
idea but it's just i would say the most
accessible entry points on the topic
and then you can go on the related work
sections to figure out
if there was some seminal paper that led
to
that line of research and of course
there is quite a bit of presenter bias
because most of these
uh works are have been cautered by me
so be mindful also that that said
do you have any questions so far i have
a quick question about uh
yeah i see that the first tip on the
model is about phrase space and neural
on super
empty i was wondering if you could talk
about the different
approaches about unsupervised learning
and also
algorithms like glove and word to work
are possible in low resource languages
yeah yeah so um
in this lecture i'm gonna focus on neuro
actually i'm not even
going in the details of the architecture
i'm more talking about
algorithms actually and so these
algorithms are applicable both to neural
a machine translation system as well as
to statistical machine translation
systems
when i go over this part i can
um uh address a little bit your question
and tell you a little bit
about the differences between the these
two
um and then in terms of
um uh methods to learn word embeddings
and
and and sentence and bearings i'm gonna
touch very briefly on that
so at the end of the lecture i'm gonna
uh
refer to some recent work on filtering
where
people use sentence embedding methods
it's not a globe but it's something
similar in a way in practice
uh for word and bearings um
it's kind of i would say
a prerequisite for machine translation
because if you can align
word embeddings you learn a dictionary
and that's
a primitive way to do machine
translation so oftentimes we look at
those things
as a good sanity check
or as a simplified machine translation
task
whenever you have a reference dictionary
for which you can then
uh check the accuracy of your alignment
but so if you let me get back to you
when uh we talk about uh this paper okay
so let's talk about data then
so uh let's go back to our english
nepali
translation task so there is
a resource called
opus which is a very nice uh
which sourced a very nice collection of
data sets all publicly available
in in lots of languages and
when you go to this website the opus
website you find that for english nepali
actually there are 1 million parallel
sentences so
maybe i lied to you telling you that
this is a low resource language but
if actually if you look at
what these corporates are you realize
that
pretty much half a million of these uh
sentences come from
uh jw 300 and
which is a religious magazine and then
you have 60 000 sentences from the bible
and their eyes come from genome eddie
ubuntu
so these are computer related materials
right
and so again unless you're interested in
translating novel
sentences from the bible this is not
super useful i would say
and so one thing to note is that all
this data originates from english you
have nothing that originates from nepali
first of all
and second of all if you are interested
in let's say translating wikipedia
all you have is wikipedia monolingual
data both in english and nepali and
nepali is not even
very much and then of course you can add
some monolingual data
in another domain like common claw which
is just a dump of the internet
but again translating between english
and nepali using
publicly available data is going to be a
challenge because
you don't have any in-domain parallel
data site
okay all you have is at most some
in-domain monolingual data
but there is an even bigger problem
which is that
there is no test data right so here
we don't have reference translations in
nepali to
measure the quality of our machine
translation system
and this is a big problem because if you
don't have a high quality
or you don't have at all a test set it's
very hard to compare
models and it's very hard to do model
selection to compare algorithms and
and our field is crippled we need
a strong evaluation uh
benchmarks and so this motivated a
project
that's called flores that stands for
facebook low resource
law resource evaluation benchmark for
machine translation
where we took wikipedia sentences
in english and translated them into
nepali and cinahla
and then we took wikipedia
we took sentences from nepali wikipedia
and translated them into english as well
as from sinaloa wikipedia and translated
them
into english okay so
you may say this is a little bit boring
because
what's hard about it and
and tell me about you know tricks to do
better modeling but actually you'd be
surprised that this data collection
process was
harder and more interesting also than we
thought
so it is hard because there are very few
uh fluent professional translators
in these languages and this is not even
super low resource right
and so since uh so uh
we died with a translator agency and
typically there are not enough people
for which you can do kind of a b testing
to test the translation of one person
with with another one
that's number one number two in general
it's very hard to assess
automatically the quality of a
translation because we don't have
enough parallel data to train machine
translation system right
and so we need to rely on other methods
than
a well-trained machine translation
system to assess the quality
and so we built a pipeline
where we would have we would send the
sentences to
the translators once the translations
are back
we would do several checks like
fluency checks using a
language model we would check for
transliteration to make sure that a
sentence is not translated by simply
transliterating
we would check that the language is the
desired one right and so we will have a
lot of checks like that and then if
and of course here there are thresholds
that you need to set somehow
and then uh for those sentences that
would fail
uh these this step
we would send them back to uh
retranslation and so after a few
iterations so this then eventually we do
also a human evaluation
and then uh the sentences in this
evaluation benchmark are those that are
that have passed that have
passed all the automatic and human
assessment
checks now um
it turns out that there is not even a
very good literature that tells you how
to collect
data and in particular for low resource
languages there are
a lot of issues uh related to the
quality of the translations and
and so this was a project that we
thought would take us a couple of months
but instead it took us
more than six months um
and that said eventually we got
a validation set a test set and also a
hidden test site because
we use this data for a wmt competition
and
and for that they needed to have a
tester that was not available to people
to make sure that people were not uh
cross-validating the test set
and here are some examples of sentences
so this is from
a sentence from the cinahla wikipedia
translating to english a couple of
sentences here and it's from english
wikipedia translating to cinahla i don't
know how many people
in the audience come from sri lanka
that could appreciate this effort but um
one interesting thing that you can
already see is that if you
although this is totally anecdotal
because it's just a couple of sentences
from
personal and english you can see that
the topic kind of topic distribution is
different
and and here you have things that
would be a little unlikely in english
wikipedia
and the same is for nepal english and
english nepali so
we have a github repository where we
host the data and also
baseline models that we train on
publicly available data and then test it
on this floor's benchmark
and last week we released another couple
of languages
english pashto and english khmer and we
are
adding more and more languages in the
coming months
so the point of this
section is just to say that data is
often time
more important than designing a model
because without data in particular
without a good evaluation benchmark
is essentially impossible to do
research in in this area
and collecting data is not review it's
not review
the process the that that you use is not
uh well established and uh
in practice it is hard to do and
another uh thing to consider sorry
is to look at the data look at the data
when you collect it
and also before you start training your
model because you may realize
some issues with the quality of the
translations
if you speak the language oftentimes
english is
on one side and or may you may discover
biases or
you may discover uh interesting things
so always look at the data
as opposed to just apply your method
in a black box way that concludes my
little discussion of
the data part are there any questions on
this
if you talk about building a language
model for low resource languages
yeah yeah yeah so in this case what we
did
uh actually we took
uh the common crawl data
and i think i actually don't remember
exactly so for nepali i think we had to
uh concatenate the wikipedia data and
the common call data because the
wikipedia data was just too small
and we simply train a count based engram
and then the count base and gives you i
don't know if you study this but it
gives you the probability of
one word given some fixed window of
context
and then uh for a given sentence we
would
like let's say what is it for a given
sentence you will
compute the score for every word and
then the score of a sentence is simply
the average
uh la probability score
uh across all the words in the sentence
and that will give you a score and then
we will simply have a threshold on that
and so all
the sentences that would score too low
that would be deemed not fluent enough
would be sent for reward
but of course whenever you have an
entity whenever you have
you know it's not super reliable and
if you go on languages that are even
lower resources than cinahla then you
have you don't even have
really in-domain data like wikipedia is
not in all the languages and then it
becomes even harder
and so often times so now that we are
scaling this up we are looking at
language models neural language models
that are trained in a multilingual way
and that are fine-tuned on a small uh
in-domain monolingual dataset
if available but yeah
also this step is not particularly
obvious how to do it yeah
sure so hi uh thank you for
like this amazing result but i just want
to comment
because like i've noticed that like
wikipedia actually will have like
different content
with different language you choose so
for example
they'll have like very detailed like
description of
some like basically topic and then in
other languages even
if with like really commonly used
language like chinese
they'll actually just have completely
different content or
basically simplified content so i'm like
pretty sure this also going to happen
with like rarely used languages
so yeah i just i just generally think
that like wikipedia might not be
like basically they might not be like
very direct reference to the trend
translation yeah
yeah yeah so it's it's an excellent
point and this is something that i'm
going to discuss more in the third part
of the lecture
and um in a way
uh this is the translation problem right
so
we need to accept the fact that content
that is originated in a certain language
may have
a different topic distribution than
content that originates in another
language
and what you want to translate is really
content that originates
in in the source language right
and so you need to to live with it that
that's uh
that's what it is so oftentimes in
um in the public benchmarks in
in the literature you find that people
assume that uh
corpora are comparable so everything
that originates in
english and let's say nepali
essentially comes from the same kind of
sources so it's news and it's
all news talking about this similar
things but
in practice this is not true it's not
true for wikipedia
as you correctly said but it's also true
for news right because
if i look at local news in nepal
and local news over here uh it's quite
different
right so this is a general problem yeah
and and this has implications in terms
of the methods that we are going to use
as we will discuss later
other questions or
i'm not sure if i was clear it's really
hard to
speak without seeing without feedback
please please let me know if anything is
not clear
okay let's talk about modeling and this
is going to be
um most of our
where we are going to spend most of our
time so remember that we have this
funky chart where we have domain and
languages and
it's a pretty complicated learning
setting
and here for simplicity we are going to
focus
just on english and nepali languages
and we start with the simplest setting
ever which is supervised learning
assuming that all data is in the same
domain
so perhaps you have a small trading site
and the test set is in the same domain
as the training side as the parallel
training side okay so we denote
as x the source sentence as y the target
sentence
d so d is uh the parallel data set
that collects all these sentence pairs
right
and so this is the typical empirical
risk minimization framework whereby you
uh you know you do supervise learning in
this case you minimize the percentage
loss and you want to
maximize the probability of the target
sentence given the source sentence
and so a way to visualize this is to say
that
x is my english sentence it goes to my
encoder decoder an nt system that
produces a prediction
and then we have a loss that measures
the discrepancy between the human
reference that
you know you took the sentence x you
asked your translator that
gave you the human reference and so the
cross entropy loss measured the
discrepancy between
the model prediction and the human
reference right
um now notice that here
i'm denoting with boxes
now model components in this case the
blue box is the
encoder the process is english sentences
and the red box is the decoder that
operates in nepali and
i just wanted to add one more thing
which is that if you don't have a lot of
parallel data
you need to regularize and so you can do
wedding k which is pretty standard so
you kind of minimize the
l2 norm of the parameters but there are
also other methods that i think
in the machine learning class you may
have seen like a dropout where you
set to zero at random uh hidden units in
your encoder decoder or you can do label
smoothing whereby you
um in your cross entropy loss instead of
actually should be more over here
instead of setting
as a target for the correct word so this
is
the probability over the whole sequence
which you can factorize over
each individual world by the product
rule
so for every word you you you have the
correct word that you want sorry
at every time step you want to predict
the next word
and now instead of assigning 100 of
probability on the
uh next word you let's say you assign 90
of the probability and the remaining 10
percent you
evenly distribute across all the
remaining words so that the model is not
too overly confident so
the combinations of these two things are
usually good ways to
um regularize the system okay so that's
the simple setting
now let's see what happens when we have
also some source side
monolingual data so here now we have
an additional data set that has only
uh sentences in the source
in the source language english so in
addition to d now we have also
uh ms which is the monolingual data on
the source
uh side so we have a bunch of axis so
typically m is much greater than n right
and now a typical way to use uh
this data is to model the marginal
distribution of the data
of x right and so there are many ways to
do that
one way that has proven to be pretty
effective
in machine translation is to do
denoising or encoding
and so here the idea is that
you have something similar to what we
had before
except that now the input is taken from
this monolingual dataset
okay and you add noise to it
and i'm going to describe the noise in
the in a second
and then the job of the encoder decoder
is simply to denoise the noisy input
and the cross entropy loss measure the
discrepancy between
the cl the prediction and the actual
clean input
but now notice that the decoder
is not this decoder because the decoder
now
is a decoder that operates in english
but the encoder does not the encoder is
is the same that you have seen here
so again the
uh the loss function here is uh very
similar to before except that
uh the target is the clean input
x and the input is
a notified version of x
so in this case we are not predicting
something nepali but something in
english
so this is a if you want a limitation of
this work
but this is useful because you are
anyway
doing some good modeling of
the input sentences and you're going to
train the encoder parameters that are
going to be
shared with your supervised system so
the encoder is shared between um
the translation task on parallel data
right and
the denoising of encoding task so
essentially you have an encoder and two
decoders one that operates in nepali one
that operates in english
and so
in terms of noise there are essentially
two types of noise that we have been
using our work
others are possible but in the simplest
case you can drop words
or swap words so assume that the input
sentence is the cash set on the mat
then if you swap words you may provided
the input
they cut the onset mat and so here
the encoder decoder needs to understand
a little bit of this
the syntax the grammatical rules in
order to reorder
if you drop let's say you drop the last
word the cassette on there
then the model needs to understand a
little bit of the semantics because it
needs to assign
a higher probability to math now right
and so you can see that there is a
little bit of
uh so there are two hyper parameters
here so one
actually there are several ways to use
the noise and encoding so you can use
the noise
encoding as a way to pre-train the
encoder
or you can use it uh as auxiliary laws
when you do supervised learning so you
can have
this term plus lambda
this term okay so both ways are fine
and uh so
there is a very critical hyperparameter
here which is the level of noise if you
don't have
any noise or if the noise level is too
low then this task is trivial because
of the attention you can simply copy the
input
and so the encoder and decoder don't
need to learn
anything if the noise level is too high
then you destroy the input here so the
encoder is
not useful you just do language modeling
using the decoder but remember that this
decoder
is then not used
used for translation because what you
use for in the machine translation
system is
is the encoder box right the encoder
module
okay so there are other ways to use
source side monolingual data
in addition to denoising of the encoding
you could also do
a self training which is a method that
comes from the 90s
if not earlier and the idea is very
simple
so again you take a sentence from your
source side monolingual data set and you
add noise to it and then you have an
encoder decoder that
tries to this time translate from this
noisy input
okay and now what's the reference the
reference is given by
a steel version of your machine
translation system
okay where the reference is produced by
let's say beam
and so uh the cross entropy loss is then
going to measure the discrepancy between
your prediction
and what the prediction from from a
stair version of your system
gave and the reason why this works is
that when you do beam
you actually typically
produce better quality
outputs and so when you train now
this encoder decoder by cross entropy
loss you're going to learn
the decoding process okay and so this is
something
uh good for you in addition
when you train you inject noise and and
the noise is regularizing it's kind of
smoothing out
uh your prediction space and so if
you're predicting correctly one sentence
now also nearby sentences by nearby i
mean
sentences that are similar phrases or
that have a good
overlap with the current sentence are
going to be
more likely predicted correctly
and so we have this paper where we
analyze a little bit these aspects and
so the algorithm
is very simple and so first you train
your machine translation system on the
parallel data
and then you repeat the following
process so first you decode your
monolingual dataset
using uh your current machine
translation system
and you make a new parallel data set
of sentences from your monolingual
dataset
with sorry with the
translations from your current system
and then you retrain the model
this pog po y given x on the union of
your
original parallel data plus this
auxiliary data set
and so here you have two hyper
parameters one
is uh the noise level and the other is
the hyper parameters the weight
these uh auxiliary data side so this set
training loss
okay now let's
so that's that concludes how we can use
uh source side monolingual data
let me say a word about how we can use
target sign monolingual data
so you could use the target simon
lingual data to train a language model
and then train the machine translation
system
in the residual space of this language
model but it turns out that there is a
much more effective way to leverage
this data and that's called back
translation
so at the high level it works as follows
so you take a sentence from
your target side monolingual dataset yt
here
and on the parallel dataset you train
also backward machine translation system
that goes from nepali to english okay
so that's so now you have a red encoder
that takes nepali and
the blue decoder that works in the
english space and so
you map this sentence into english
it's the pali sentence to english and
now this
may not be a correct translation but
it's a noisy
input that you fit to your encoder
decoder that
you want to train right and so now
the input is noisy but the target here
is clean because it comes from the
original target
monolingual dataset and so
this is a very powerful algorithm
because um
unlike cell training here the targets
are clean
but the input is a little noisy and
that's
usually much better than having clean
inputs but noisy targets right because
the targets affect
essentially all the arrow signals that
you propagate through the
nmt systems
and this and you can see by translation
is a way to do data augmentation
because you produce noisy version
of inputs for a given target a little
bit like in vision where they do
well i guess this is not the right
audience to to do this analogy but if
you have work on vision you
you will do scaling rotation different
cropping and that's a little bit similar
to what we are doing here
and so uh the algorithm again is you
train a
backbone and a forward machine
translation system on the parallel data
and then you use your backward model to
decode
the target side monolingual dataset to
produce an auxiliary parallel dataset
and then you concatenate the
the two datasets the original data set
and the auxiliary one to train
the new forward model okay
of course you can combine satrani and
bad translation so if you have both
source monolingual dataset and target
monoming with dataset
you can do the following so you can use
the parallel data to train the forward
and the backward machine translation
system
and then at the step two you can
use the forward model to decode
to translate the source side monolingual
dataset
into this data and you can use
the backward machine translation system
to
translate the target simulink with the
decide into these
translations okay and then you treat
these parallel sentences as real data
and you concatenate them to the parallel
data set
and now you retrain both the forward and
the backward machine translation systems
and now as long as these two improve
then you can go
and do another iteration whereby you
again you read the code
you re-translate the source and the
target sign on remote data sets and then
you go
and you retrain them
and this is as far as you know the most
effective way to leverage monolingual
data
in low resource languages nowadays
let me talk a little bit about how we
can do
multilingual training so in this case we
have
parallel data sets but on different
language pairs
and so you have a para data set for
english nepali one for english hindi one
for
hindi english or nepali hindi or any
subset of these
and this is super simple so the way that
it works is that you have a single
encoder and a single decoder
okay and you train by supervised
learning
the only change that needs to be made is
that
at the input of the encoder you
concatenate
also a token that specifies the language
in which you want to translate and so
the encoder will learn to process
multiple languages
the decoder will learn to to
produce multiple languages as well
and it will pick the language based on
the token specified by
in the encoder input and so
training is just minimizing the
cross-entropy loss for all the parallel
datasets that you have
where you simply add an extra token
uh in the source sentence that specifies
the target
language that you want to translate
and the only thing that i wanted to add
on this is that oftentimes
it taps if you pre-process the data
by i'm not sure if you learn about
bipartisan coding sentence pieces
essentially
ways to segment words into
syllables or frequent character engrams
and so if you concatenate this data in
order to learn these ways to segment the
data then
it's also possible that for many
languages there is a good fraction of
the dictionary that is shared
and so this also helps making sure that
you can do a good job translating
multiple languages at one
at once and so
uh my the conclusion so far is that even
without domain effect
there are a lot of training paradigms
depending on the available data that you
have
a priori it's very hard to tell which
method works best nowadays because it
really depends on
how much data you have
how different are the domains and what
is the language power that you're
working with
for instance the domains may be very
different but
if you have a lot of data maybe it
doesn't matter much
in practice we have key ingredients
denoising of encoding
bad translation multilingual training
that
work pretty well and nowadays
the field is at the stage in which we
are trying to figure out the best way to
combine them and right now there is a
lot of
what i would say craftsmanship uh to
figure out how to best combine them
and um but hopefully we can find
and i think there is a lot of effort in
trying to automate this process because
right now
um there is a lot of cross-validation i
would say to
figure out all these hyper parameters
um so the open challenges here
are dealing with the diversity of domain
domains dealing with data sets that have
a very widely different
translation quality some are very noisy
some are very clean
dealing with different with data sets of
different size
and very different language pairs
and yeah and so i would say that in
general it may be counterintuitive but
working low resource machine translation
doesn't mean
training small models on small data but
actually means training
even bigger models on even more data
because you need to compensate for the
lack of supervision
that you have of direct supervision that
you have
very good before i go on are there any
questions
um yeah i just had a quick question
regarding um in the
in a few of the previous algorithms that
you described
um is it necessary to retrain entirely
um like retrain the model entirely or is
there some way to augment the
model or fine-tune it on the
um on the generated so actually
what usually happens is that as you
iterate
you can make the model bigger so
when you turn on the parallel dataset
usually this is not much data and so you
need to train in something small
otherwise you
overheat too much but once you add
uh the monolingual data that you
this 80 data set then this model
can be much bigger than the original
model
now it's not
super obvious how to
you know initialize a bigger model from
a smaller model
so that's why people usually initialize
from random
at the next iterations you can
initialize from the model at the
previous iteration
what we usually find is that
initializing at random
usually works as well
thank you thank you
okay any other question
when you say uh you usually the model
learns
uh i was wondering do you mean that you
add uh
more layers or the more parameters uh as
the model keeps training
oh usually you just make a bigger
yeah the more layers more parameter so
whether it is wider or deeper
[Music]
i think usually
yeah i'm not entirely sure there is a
definite answer on that
[Music]
usually making the encoder deeper is a
good thing
making the decoder deeper doesn't buy
you much
um so usually we play with the encoder i
would say
and um but yeah
there is not so much difference in
practice uh i would say
um yeah so you can imagine just double
the size of your hidden state
that would work
okay okay
so let's see how this so i i didn't
speak about models but i spoke about
algorithms you can turn these algorithms
into
models a little bit and talk about joint
distribution marginal distribution but
in my view it's just simpler to think in
terms of
algorithms because also the way that
we implement them and so let's see how
these algorithms can be
put together in some interesting case
studies
so actually i realize that i'm really
going slow
so let's see the case where you only
have monolingual data and no parallel
data
so this is what we call unsupervised
machine translation
so let's say that you have an english
and a french data set
this is not a typical use case of a
supervised machine translation but this
is where
it works really well so let's focus for
this for now
and so you take a sentence from the
target seminal dataset you go through
your encoder decoder and you produce
an english translation obviously you
don't have the reference here
so what you could do is to fit this to
a machine translation system that goes
from english to french
so that you kind of reconstruct your
original french sentence and now you
have
you can have a narrow signal to back
propagate through your
machine translation system you can do
the same going from
english to french to english this is
very much what people have done in
vision
they call it psycho consistency you can
see this as a not encoder where the
intermediate
representation is
you know is a language in english
the problem is that as it is the model
is not constrained to produce something
that is
a fluent english sentence so
in the region domain people use
adversarial training but
in nlp it's kind of tricky because this
is a discrete sequence and so
in order to make sure that this decoder
produces english
fluent english sentences you could
imagine to do
the noise and encoding right so you
could take and not uh you could take an
english sentence nosify
go through your denoiser auto encoding
now this decoder is the same block that
you have here
is going to be forced to learn the
statistics and the regularities of
the english language
the problem is that if you look at this
decoder
this decoder is in the denoising auto
encoding game
it is operating on the output of this
encoder that takes english as input well
here
encoder takes french as input it could
be very well be the case that
the representation produced by these two
encoders
is different so this decoder may work
very well in the setting but
not in this setting and so in other ways
how can we make sure that
these red and blue blocks are
interchangeable
how can we make sure that there is good
modularity
and so so one way to do this is to use
the trick that we use
for multilingual training whereby we
have a single encoder
and a single decoder so the decoder is
shared across
french and english and the encoder is
english and french and we specify the
target language by
an extra token at the input
and so in particular if you learn uh
common bps and if you share parameters
then this process
sorry this process really works well and
and you having
a decoder that operates well with
whenever it is fed with the hidden state
that comes from
an encoder operating on english or
french
and so again the key ingredients are
iterated by translation
denoising encoding and multilingual
training
and for unsupervised machine translation
we do
bad translation in an online manner
whereby for a given mini batch
we do bad translation we don't do it
uh with the stale version of the model
but you could do
that that works less well
and so when you do this on english
friends you find that
actually you can get pretty good
performance a blue of 30
usually gives you pretty fluent
translations that are uh
also adequate and uh if you compare that
to what you got with the
supervised baseline that is trained on
the parallel data set you find that
training on 10 million monolingual
sentences
in english and a million french gives
you the same
translation accuracy than training a
supervised baseline that is
this red
curve actually this red curve this blue
curve and this the curve this is the
neural version this is the phrase based
version
with hundred thousand parallel sentences
so
in other words each
parallel sentence pair is equivalent to
hundred monolingual sentences
equivalent in the sense that they give
you a machine translation system
of similar
accuracy and so
now the more the domains are different
and the more
the languages are different from each
other
the worst it gets and so that's why when
you do
larger machine translation this is the
extreme case of unsupervised machine
translation you need to
learn from lots of data in order to
compensate for the
lack of the rat supervision
i'm going to maybe
give you an example on flores where
for the flores as we have seen there was
no in domain
parallel data there was some monolingual
data that was in domain
but not very much and there was quite a
bit of autumn
out of domain parallel data you remember
the 1 million sentences
from bible and ubuntu
and then we have quite a bit of
monolingual data that is auto domain
and so this is the supervised baseline
and unsupervised machine translation
here didn't work at all because
very much like was mentioned that the
wikipedia domains are not quite
uh aligned and so this doesn't have
unsupervised machine translation if you
do
back translation if you do iterated by
translation you do quite a bit better
than the supervised baseline
which is quite good but now if you add
also english hindi parallel data you do
quite a bit better and now also the
unsupervised machine translation works
it's a supervised for
english nepali but you do have
supervision for english hindi
and so the combination of bad
translation and
multilingual training is here the
winning combination
and this is something that we see uh
through in general
okay so i'm gonna skip the results on
english vermees
actually i had a nice demo but i'm going
to show it to you later if there is time
and so as i said we have
quite a few good components which we can
combine pretty easily
right now the research is about how to
best combine them how to best
weight data sets how to best with
examples in order to automate
the current cross-validation based
process i would say and
the other message here is that it's
resource machine translation is a big
data problem it it requires big compute
it's a pretty big engineering feat
in order to compensate for the lack of
parallel data are there any questions on
this
i was just wondering when you mentioned
that the parallel to
vision and cycle consistency you
mentioned that we can't do adversarial
training yeah and i was just wondering
if you could flash that out and why we
couldn't just use say like an lstm
and perform um adversarial training
yeah yes yes so there are actually a
bunch of papers trying to do
um adversarial training or
uh gun style training for
uh tax generation i must say that
it's a pretty active uh research area i
haven't seen
a very compelling demonstration that
these methods work very well with tried
and it's a little difficult to propagate
so
when this produces a sentence you need
to produce
a you know a sentence and that's
discrete
and so you could propagate using
reinforce kind of methods you could
do a lot of these things but essentially
it's just a little hard to make it work
and it's very finicky
so it may work on simple data sets but
at scale
it's very hard to so another thing
another consideration is that
anything that you do has to work at
scale because
again the value the amount of
information that you get from a
monolingual sentence is not very much
and now if you do a lot of compute if
you or if your gradients have
a lot of noise like when you drink with
rainforest then
it's not going to work it's possible
that
people may come up with ways to make it
work i don't think
this is through at present but it could
be in the future
so let me spend five minutes on the
analysis um
and then you will have the slides so you
can uh go
over the remaining details so here uh
we so the starting point is to say well
if i
were to simulate low resource machine
translation with a high resource
language like french to english
let's say you take europa data you have
let's say 20 000 parallel sentences and
hundred thousand
lingual target sentences and you applied
by translation you got a very nice
improvement
now if you come here on facebook and you
try this on
facebook data you find that the
improvement is actually
very very minimal and that relates to
the discussion that we had at the very
beginning that
what people talk about in different
parts of the world is very different
and so now you you need it's like you
need to align
two point clouds but the distribution of
these two point clouds is
very very different from each other so
it's very difficult to align them
and so here i was making the example
that even for english speaking countries
if you look at
topics on on sports you have that
in the in america people may talk more
about football and baseball
in the uk more about cricket and soccer
right
and so for the same topic you have a
different distribution words but you
also have this
different distribution of topics
and so this is what we call the source
target domain mismatch so
you may have several kinds of domain
mismatch typically
you have a mismatch between the training
distribution and the test distribution
here i'm talking also about a mismatch
between the source
domain the source language the source
domain and the target domain
okay and so there is a hypothesis that
this may make
that translation less effective because
even if you were to perfectly translate
target side monolingual data once you
translate it
it's going to be out of domain
with respect to the data that you really
want to translate which originates in
the source domain
and so we had a very
nice control setting to study this
problem
where we create a synthetic
data set where the source domain comes
from euro parliament data and the target
domain comes from open subtitles which
are moving captions
and now by creating the target domain as
a mixture of the
two you can precisely control the amount
of
indomaineness between the source and the
target domain
and by varying alpha you can vary that
and so the major result
is this figure where alpha measures how
much
is the target domain uh similar to the
source domain so if five
is equal to one they are all uh in the
same domain if i
is equal to zero they are very different
one is euro par and the other is open
subtitles
and so it turns out that in this extreme
regime
actually self training which is this red
line
works better than bad translation but as
you make the domains more and more
similar
that translation is much better than set
training
and both of them are much better than um
just if you were to use the parallel
data
um so i'm gonna skip all of this you can
look at the
paper and the slides
i want to conclude that there are other
things that i didn't talk about like
filtering this is one of the most
exciting things
nowadays and the idea is to
essentially learn a joint embedding
space for sentences
by simply training a multi-lingual
system on lots of public available data
and then you use this in order to do
nearest neighbor retrieval of a sentence
for what
the corresponding translation would be
in other languages
and they found that they collected a
large dataset
and they were able to beat the
performance of state-of-the-art
machine translation system on high
resource languages like
english german english russian and
the idea is that by using much more data
although noisy you can do better than
using
a curated high quality data set and this
is
something that we see over and over and
again the idea here is that
we need to figure out how to best
combine by translation this filtering
multilingual and pre-training
in order to get
the best combination ever for solving
or for improving low resource machine
translation and so
i just want to maybe i should conclude
here
uh by thanking my collaborators and by
uh telling you that um
if you have any questions about this
lecture you can always
email me drop me a line i'd be happy to
follow up and also
in my lab we have a lot of opportunities
from
internships to full-time positions as a
research scientist research engineer so
if you're interested or are curious just
also
drop me an email okay thank you
thanks a lot malcolm elio um
so so maybe there's still a few people
that might have
questions and you're happy to stay a few
more minutes for questions
happy to ask a question yes
uh okay i'd love to learn more about the
models that you've used
actually if you go back to the model did
you first talk about
spoke about right before back
translation i wanted to understand
uh you have a pipeline from english to
english right
in this one uh you want something like
you the data augmentation
techniques like envision such as
dropping the word or switching
switching words to be able to make an
augmented data status right
that's right so the analogy that i made
is
for bad translation where yes all these
methods essentially
you don't have x and y golden x and y
pairs and so for cell training
what you do you fantasize the target
for that translation you fantasize the
input
and so you can see all these methods as
a way in particular by translation it's
very similar to
the data augmentation that people do in
vision in the sense that
here the transformation is not
rule-based it's produced by a backbone
machine translation system but
it has the same objective of
regularizing by adding a lot of noisy
uh level data so and if you go back to
the previous slide when you say you
fantasize
the target so in this case you have uh
one where you predict the gold target
and one where you you change the input
and then predict the target is that how
it is
yeah so in for set training the way that
it works is that
you take the clean input you pass it
through
your machine translation system at the
previous iteration
and you decode with beam or with other
methods and you got
a prediction for what the label should
be and
that that's now your reference but
the way that you train your machine
translation system is by noisifying the
input
so you add noise to your input and the
noise is you drop words you swap words
and then you try to predict the uh
target
that you fantasize and the idea is that
the two targets should be the same
yeah so the prediction and and these
targets
when you train with cross entropy loss
you try to tie them together as much as
possible
okay thanks so much i'd love to follow
the question
yeah this is a very this is one of the
first semi-supervised
learning methods that you find in the
machine learning community
there are a lot of variants of this
where they have perhaps a
community of experts that produces the
label there are a lot of variants of
this and
it's something that makes a lot of sense
particularly for
asymmetric tasks like if you do image
specif
if you do text classification if you do
summarization then
that translation is not really
applicable because uh
you know if you go from a label category
from a categorical uh input to
a whole sentence that's a very difficult
task right
so by translation works really well for
symmetry tasks like uh
machine translation but for uh things
that are
for many to one mapping sub training is
definitely
definitely works better assad training
works well
also in machine translation when there
is a lot of domain mismatch between the
source and the target as person
yeah so unfortunately these algorithms
so it's hard to say in general
what works best because it really
depends on the application it really
depends on the kind of data that you
have
does anyone else have a question they'd
like to ask
well it seems like we're maybe not
getting another immediate question
and i guess we have gone till the end of
the time that
um we're meant to do it so maybe we
should call it
and bring it to a close but thank you so
much marcorellio
i mean i hope everyone really enjoyed
that and i
you know speaking of someone who did
work in machine translation for a decade
though i haven't so much the last few
years
i mean you know it actually still
seems to me just amazing how
successfully
you can build things um with these um
building with monolingual data and using
ideas
like the back translation i mean it's
just actually incredible that that's
providing such competitive um
machine translation systems now and you
know obviously this is something that
isn't just
of academic interests as you might have
realized if you've thought about it
right if you're
got a company like facebook right being
actually able to
translate well data on
domains that are very far from news days
out or the bible
and in languages that are smaller
communities of speakers
is just actually super duper important
to
people being happy users of and members
of communities
yeah and and i just want to add uh the
kind of
these methods are pretty generous so we
apply them to summarization
q and a uh style transfer
so you know it's really beautiful
it's a set of tools that you can use
them
in many places and it's all about you
know in a way
aligning domains with little uh
supervision or correspondences right so
yeah okay thank you very much thank you
thank you bye bye